>>Mark: One of our core values
is achieving social justice.
And this is something that, I mean,
it kind of defines what we do.
Our Founder and Head
of Schools often talks
about education being the
civil rights issue of our day.
And I couldn't agree more.
And it goes back to this idea
of giving 100 percent every day.
When you think about the civil rights
activists, they didn't take time
to ask themselves, "Do I
have energy left to give?"
If you truly believe that this
is an issue of civil rights,
then it kind of inspires
you to give more
than you thought you
were able to give.
And then when you look at
our demographic of students
at this school, 83 percent
of our students qualify
for free or reduced lunch.
We don't have the exact numbers
yet for at-risk, but I would guess
that roughly half of our
students are considered at-risk.
It's just a very high need
segment of the population,
and historically under-served.
And so when we say,
"Achieving social justice,"
what we mean is we are giving
opportunities to students
that they would not get at another
school, but we believe are kind
of just baseline opportunities.
All students in America should
have access to excellent education,
and that currently isn't the case.
And so we're here to kind
of level the playing field.
>>Mark: We're looking to not just
give students a baseline education,
but look for ways to enhance that.
So that involves implementing
programs that they wouldn't get,
maybe, at their traditional
public school.
It includes going on field lessons
or field trips to different colleges
around the country, exposing them
to college, so that it's not just,
"Yeah, we're going to
send you to college,
or you're going to get into college."
But it's very much, "We're going
to provide you opportunities along
the way, so that when it's time to go
to college you've been
exposed to that opportunity,
and you're ready for it."
>>Mark: I've been asked a number
of times what makes YES
Prep North Central great.
And I've even had people
say, "You know,
what do you do to make it great?"
And I'm not being falsely
humble here, like it's not me.
It's people, people, people.
It's the teachers that we have here.
And so we have a very clearly
defined way that we recruit teachers.
And we use, basically, a personality
profile to ensure that the people
who come to work here are not
just dedicated to this idea
of social justice, but they're also
dedicated to working in a team,
and they're dedicated to being part
of something greater than themselves.
So we work really hard to make sure
that we've got the right people,
and then once we have them here, we
work really hard to keep them here.
>>Mark: You know, it's challenging
for me sometimes as a leader,
because your tendency is to want
to keep control of everything.
And what I realize more and more
is that leadership can be this--
you can think of it as this pyramid.
And the more that I sort of
sit up top on the pyramid
and keep the authority to myself and
keep the decision-making to myself,
the more likely our school
is to become stagnant
and just become basically
a microcosm of me.
And that's the last
thing I would want.
And so I intentionally hire
people who are different than me.
I intentionally look for ways to
have people on my leadership team,
and have people in my
school who push me.
Just making sure that there are as
many voices in this school onboard
and feel like they have a voice,
and I think that makes
it much more genuine.
>>Mark: I really fight hard to
not micromanage my teachers.
I think of it as I'm the
support there for them.
I've used the analogy with
them before of being oxygen.
And that if things are going well,
I sort of fade into the background.
But if I'm not doing my job,
or things aren't going well,
then they're suffocating and
they know I'm not doing my job.
So it's very much like find the
right people, and spend a lot
of time doing that, and then
just let them run the school.
And in a lot of ways, they have a
lot of autonomy here at this school.
>>Mark: Teachers are each provided a
cell phone from the school in order
to make themselves accessible
to students twenty-four hours
a day, seven days a week.
And the idea being is that students
aren't allowed to use the excuse
that they didn't understand
something.
And it, again, exemplifies that idea
that we want teachers building this
positive relationship with students.
So that doesn't just happen
during the school day.
It happens at night.
If a student has an issue that comes
up at night, they have an avenue
to get in touch with
the teacher directly,
and we pay the cell phone
bill for the teachers.
But so students use that for personal
reasons, but they also use it
if they have a question on their
homework, and they need help,
they can call their teacher.
So that the next day they
can't come in and say,
"I didn't understand
something, so I didn't do it."
They always have an avenue to
look for, to reach out for help.
>>Mark: Working 100 percent
every day means different things
to different people.
Some things that, I think, are
pretty common when people talk
about it is the availability
that we talked about earlier.
Are you available to your students
past the normal school hours, which,
I think, is probably 8:00 to 3:30,
and we're in school from 7:30
until 4:30 Monday through Friday.
So are you available those
times, which are already longer?
Then on top of that,
are you available
to your students outside
of those hours?
Are you available to pick up
the phone when they call you
at 9:00 upset about a fight that
they've had with their parents?
Are you available to return a phone
call when they ask about homework
that you gave that
they don't understand?
Then when you're in the
classroom, we're not okay
with just average lessons.
They need to be high energy, high
impact lessons that are going
to ensure that students who
are here for-- what is that?
Nine hours a day?
Are making sure that during those
nine hours that they're here,
they're not getting, eh, four to
five hours of great instruction.
But they're getting
as close to nine hours
of great instruction as possible.
>>Mark: Burn-out is something that we
have to deal with, but we work hard
as administrators to find ways to
relieve teachers and kind of try
and provide some balance in a
job that's inherently unbalanced.
You know, we do things like making
sure they have common planning times.
So that they aren't having
to meet after school.
After school they can spend time with
students, or if they need to go home
and spend some time with their
families, they can do that,
but try and maximize the time
that they have in school.
So common planning
times is one of them.
We also have a weekly early dismissal
on Wednesdays where teachers gather
to do professional development.
And sometimes if we don't have
something really well-planned,
then we'll do something fun like
have a staff volleyball game,
or a staff picnic or
a staff barbeque.
Just something to continually
draw on our strength
of relationships with each other.
>>Mark: We don't have fights,
because we don't allow fights.
And I believe that if
we lowered that bar--
just like if you lower an academic
bar, if you lower a behavior bar,
what it ends up doing is
it makes things permissible
that shouldn't be permissible.
And if we're going to call
ourselves a family-oriented school--
now, I know families fight-- we're
not going to have people getting
in fist-fights in the hallway,
and say, "That's okay,"
by allowing them to stay.
And thinking about the course of
this year, we've had two fights,
and for a middle school and a high
school, I mean, it's remarkable.
And I guess you can write it
off and say, "Oh, yeah, well,
you got to hand pick the
student who were here,
and so they're not
prone to fighting."
I would disagree.
A) We didn't handpick them, because
we do an open enrollment lottery;
B) Middle school students
and high school students,
period, are prone to fighting.
And what we need to do is educate
them about the alternatives.
And so we have a social worker
on-staff, a full-time social worker.
We're looking to expand that role.
Every day students are in advisor
meeting with a group of teachers.
So we're looking for ways not just
to say, "Oh, students don't fight,"
but how do we educate students
so that fighting isn't their first
choice, they have other alternatives.
>>Mark: The first group
that came here, they left,
and their parting words to
me were, "This is possible.
We can do this."
And I believe that, right?
It's possible.
Is it going to look
exactly like what we do?
No, I don't think you can take it
and just kind of cookie-cutter,
lay it on top of whatever
you're doing at your school.
But are the ideas here?
Are they possible?
Absolutely.
And what you have to have
is a sense of a possibility.
I mean, it's not going to be easy,
and we've been working at this
for ten years, and we still
have a ton of stuff to do.
So there aren't any quick
fixes, I don't think.
I think it requires a ton of hard
work, and I mentioned this earlier,
and I believe this, that it involves
people seeing education as much more
than just a job that you go to, but
you would give it the same passion
that you would give it
if you truly believed
that someone's life was in danger.
So I think about a doctor.
If a doctor is saving someone's
life, they're not going to stop
because the workday ends.
They're going to keep going
and doing whatever it takes
to make sure that happens.
And if you had more people thinking
like that, that this would--
that our nation's health depends
on how well we're educating
our students;
if you had more people
completely bought into that idea,
that their welfare is directly
tied to the students' welfare,
I think it's absolutely possible.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.